i never thought that i would be talking
about
why they shouldn't support communism i
thought we would have learned that
lesson
over 30 years ago how would you define
socialism
common ownership of the means of
production so historically
socialism that's what it is ussr union
of soviet socialist republics
it's the final transitionary step to
communism do you think america is
eventually going to get to point of
losing citizens
possibly i mean ronald reagan said if we
lose freedom here there's no place to
escape to this is the last stand on
earth
well it's true if we lose freedom here
where else are we going to go to
in fact ronald reagan came from an era
where people could disagree
but you get this kind of mob media
platform
this culture of intimidation of cancel
and it starts going after people and i
find that
one of the more disturbing things about
america today
and also two people just aren't well
read they're not taking the time to
research things
but this is the kind of culture that
we're in 30 plus years after the
collapse of communism
we should not be having the debate as to
whether or not communism is bad
and the fact that we are shows we're
really in trouble as a country
[Music]
we have a special guest with us here
today he is paul kanger who is the
best-selling author professor historian
and commentator and we're going to focus
on two topics today one topic
is going to be karl marx which he wrote
a book that just came out i think august
of 2020
a few months ago thousand plus reviews
on amazon it's been a big hit
it's called the devil in karl marx
communism's long march of death
deception and infiltration and we're
going to focus on a second individual
in today's interview and that is reagan
ronald reagan
which he paul wrote a book called the
crusader ronald reagan in the fall of
communism in 20
2006 which is turning into a movie
starring dennis quit it's going to have
jon voight and a lot of other folks in a
great lineup of uh
but it's based on the book that my guest
today wrote with that being said paul
thank you so much for being a guest on
by team
well thank you patrick i'm very
impressed with you your background and
it's
um it's it's a joy to be with you thanks
thank you you know i've watched your
videos and the way you explain
things i i told you this off uh
you know before the interview getting
started i said you're extremely
necessary today and i hope the audience
gets a lot out of our interviews so
you know paul if we can start what makes
somebody like you want to a historian
can study a lot of different things it
can be war
some are world war one some two some
it's a different war
some it's military some it's history
having to do with
different characters but why the focus
on
karl marx and ronald reagan well that's
a good question patrick so i
it goes it goes back to i'd say my kind
of formative years in college
i was in college in the late 1980s i
went to the university of pittsburgh
where i where i was pre-med and i
i worked for the organ transplant team
at the university of pittsburgh so i
know
you probably didn't expect me to say
this right this to be part of my answer
but but i was i the
doctor thomas starzel was the organ
transplantation pioneer they did 80 to
of the world's organ transplants at the
university of pittsburgh in the 1980s so
so i was there right so this is this is
my life this is my career
this is where i'm going i'm going to go
to medical school
i i i worked 30 hours a week
while i was in college for three years
and then when i graduated i worked full
time
did research on immunology
anti-rejection drugs
but it was 1988 1989
and it was the collapse of communism the
end of the cold war
the end of the reagan presidency mikhail
gorbachev
margaret thatcher pope john paul ii lek
valessa in poland vaclav havel and
czechoslovakia the solidarity movement
the iran contras the mujahideen in
afghanistan all this stuff right
so i was really intrigued by it and
well i could say a lot i don't want to
go off on too much of a tangent but i
i'll tell you
i was non-political i was
non-ideological
and i knew all these great debates were
going on around me i started following
them i started paying attention
i wrote a letter to the editor to the
student newspaper which was called the
pit news which was a daily newspaper
published four days a week monday
through thursday the editor said hey i
i really like this i'm gonna i'm gonna
run this as an article if you don't mind
and he ran it as an article it was
called by the way it was about
the homeless and as a as a
science major a non-political person
non-ideological person
i heard these people on campus who i was
told were were liberals
right and they were blaming the homeless
problem on ronald reagan
and i thought how is this year was this
what year was this when you wrote this
just
would have been 1988 1989 got it so the
liberals are blaming ronald reagan
homeless continue i'm sorry right right
so so i did a little research on it like
a science major would do right
so i tried to find out i read some
different publications i talked to some
homeless people
i called the local homeless shelter and
i asked the lady at the local homeless
shelter i said hey um
so i'm doing some research on this as a
student i asked her a bunch of questions
and then at the end of this patrick at
the end at the end of the interview i
said okay
so why is this ronald reagan's fault and
she said
young man ronald reagan's fault these
people are mentally ill
i don't know what they're teaching you
at that university right
well i know they're not all mentally ill
but this was her response right
and and and so i wrote this up in the
student newspaper
for the students they published it as a
column and i got called
a racist probably for the first time in
my life right
i got called a fascist my so
the next article that i wrote by the way
this is symptomatic of i think
me and you both right when they attacked
me
i didn't crawl under a rock i said i
said damn it that's not right
right um i'm gonna respond to this so i
wrote another article
on on arming the contras in nicaragua
which i thought seemed like a common
sense thing to do i don't know why
people on campus were protesting this
why wouldn't you oppose communism i
wrote that piece and i got called
a nazi of all things a nazi right
a fascist i remember my father picking
me up from
from class on a friday afternoon give me
a ride home he said hey how's that
newspaper column thing going that you're
doing
i said oh pretty pretty good dad i said
you know this is amazing
i got called a nazi for the last column
i wrote he said a what
i said a nazi a nazi i still remember
him looking at me in the car
a nazi yeah i said yeah yeah he said
what are you writing about hitler i said
no i'm not writing about hitler
dad i said there's these people on
campus they're called liberals
and when you disagree with them they
savage you
they call you the worst names in the
book they're calling me all these
different names
and he said well you know hang in there
i said oh i'm going to hang in there
so i continued to write and then pretty
soon i ended up becoming
the campus conservative the editorial
page editor
they call me all these different names
and here's the big picture to kind of
long answer to your question
it was the end of the cold war it was
the collapse of communism it was 1989 so
this is what i wrote about
and i became really really intrigued
with the end of the cold war
communism all these different ideologies
and
long process i'll sum this up in 30
seconds
this was long and agonizing but i
decided not to go to medical school
to instead go to graduate school i went
to american university in washington the
school of international service
and took up studying international
affairs
the soviet union eastern europe the
middle east
i teach middle east politics to this day
at grove city college in grove city
pennsylvania
and and i that became sort of my calling
i guess that's what i started writing
books on
and i started writing books specifically
in the collapse of communism the reagan
presidency
end of the cold war and patrick i
thought
i'd be writing from communism from a
historical perspective right
this is bad this is evil here's how many
people this ideology killed
so forth i never thought that in the
year 2021
i would be talking about i'm trying to
teach people why this is bad
why they shouldn't support communism i
thought we would have learned that
lesson
over 30 years ago let me let me ask you
this by the way uh
powerful right there on your testimony
how you came about what a timing 8889
reagan communism
clashed and it makes sense to why
wanting to study those two figures but
question for you 88.89 versus today
88.89
we didn't see what happened on campus
there was no videos that somebody was
protesting against you we didn't see any
of that
that was taking place around the country
we didn't see that hardcore liberal the
media would have to go there to record
it
versus today how big of a difference is
it between 88 89
versus 2020 2021 well i started seeing a
lot of this stuff back then
and that was when the very first article
by dinesh d'souza
on the cover of atlantic monthly right
which is the atlantic magazine
and that was his book ill liberal
education
that was sort of the start of the
political correctness movement
and it's funny that we're having this
conversation i i'm a senior editor for
the american spectator i'm writing the
history
of the american spectator which i read
in the late 1980s
and i was going back through that period
89 90
and i and and and i went back and
grabbed from an old box in my basement
the articles that i wrote
for my student newspaper and the last
one that i wrote
was titled something like um favorite
columnist which is like a sarcastic
thing right
says goodbye to some unthoughtful words
not with some unthoughtful words to some
unthoughtful words
and i went through words like fascists
nazi racist homophobe hater
you could get called all these words
even if you weren't these things
right just for simply opposing liberals
and leftists
on on this stuff so this sort of
demonization
of opponents that was already going on
i i think the difference now what's so
dangerous and sad about the current
period
is because of social media and media
platforms today
you can really get a quite literal right
twitter mob
against somebody yep and you know people
can come after you
and mass by the thousands and millions
and there just wasn't that sort of you
know alacrity
speed of protest of organizing
that that you that you see today but um
but that
but that stuff was out there back then
and i remember too one more
june 1989 um two things in june 1989.
the um the people of poland held free
and fair elections
all right which had been promised at
yalta in 1945
44 years later all right that same week
everybody forgets was
this was the same week tiananmen square
happened
in china and i remember the chinese
students
on my campus university of pittsburgh
who came up to me as the conservative
that they knew of on the student
newspaper
and they said we're looking to
demonstrate we're looking to hold a
protest
we want some people to march with us
how do we find the protesters and i kind
of laugh patrick cause i thought you
know these guys aren't going to protest
this right i mean
they're protesting arming the contras
you know they're protesting
apartheid in south africa right but
they're not on the streets protesting
what's going on in tiananmen square
and these poor kids they protested they
marched alone
and they marched alone on pit campus
they had paper bags over their heads
to conceal their identities they wore
bandanas over their mouth
so so the regime back home wouldn't know
who they were
but that was one of those lessons too
that the american left
man on a dime they would protest what
was happening in
chile under pinochet right years earlier
under
cuba under batista in the 50s right
what was going on in south africa but
you get you know a communist crackdown
on pro-democracy demonstrators in
beijing
you know if you pressed them and said
this is bad right they might say yeah
it's bad but they weren't they weren't
marching in the streets over it
you know so so a lot of that stuff that
we're seeing today
was around it's been around for years
let me let me ask you so
i got three questions for you so let me
write down the third one so i can kind
of uh
uh uh get to it here okay so number one
question is the following
when i was in the army they told me when
you go in as much as i used to curse a
lot because i
you know pre-25 i cursed i was a cursing
machine so when you go in the army
you know how they say they curse like
you know you curse like a sailor or you
know all that stuff
everybody dropped the f-bomb and when i
tell you f-bomb it was like every other
award like
adjective adverb noun it doesn't matter
what it was right i grew up with guys
like that yeah okay
so i was one of those guys yeah yeah i
gotta tell you paul
after about a couple weeks i never heard
the f word anymore
like i couldn't even hear it so i get
out of the army i'm working at valley
total fitness and chatsworth my friend
at the time fernando says
pat do you know how foul of a language
you gotta say what do you mean
he says every other word out of your
mouth is and you're talking to customers
like this like
let me see what i can often get you and
i know hey what's up mother
so go on you just did it again i'm like
oh she says you may want to kind of if
you want to kind of become a manager
here one day you got to clean up your
language so you know what i wasn't
aware of it so i kind of worked on it
here's my point
do you think the weight behind the word
nazi racist bigot has lost
its weight because everybody's thrown
around nowadays where it no longer has
the weight at once hand
or do you think it still carries weight
yeah it it it should
it should carry far less weight and and
i i mean especially today where
you know you can get called that for
anything for any reason
and this is something that i i've tried
to tell liberal friends of mine for
years right
you call somebody a fascist right well
watch out because when the real mccoy
comes along someday no one's going to
believe you when you call out somebody
who's really a fascist
you call everyone a racist no one's
going to believe you when someone comes
along who's genuinely a racist
and by the way i say this to
conservative friends a lot
just because someone's a liberal you
disagree with them don't call him akami
right you know you know communism is a
very
unique specific thing you know you might
call him a radical lefty right call him
a lefty crazy
call him a loony left something like
that but but you know don't fling that
kind of language around both sides need
to be more careful and thoughtful about
their rhetoric
and their names but the left in
particular i mean you know i've had
people
people say to me i've heard this i've
heard this more in the past six months
or so
especially after the trump
administration right um
that people just simply no longer take
that charge of racist
seriously because the left has
absolutely
so abused it and annihilated it that it
doesn't carry the weight
that that uh that it should yeah it's
funny you say that i had
uh david horowitz on you know david
horowitz yeah he was a
pretty well known grove city college
yeah a couple years ago
amazing yep yeah i had him on and he
kept saying everybody the democrats are
coming as i said you can't say that he
says i'm telling you they're coming out
i don't believe every one of them is
because we're losing them he says
everybody keeps saying so anyways we had
a nice interesting conversation together
on
because i agree with you on the fact
that we're also labeling everybody not
everybody's in the same box
second question for you on this side
here so for me
as a person that's a business owner i'm
an entrepreneur i have to always get to
the bottom of the issue because
you can fix issues on the surface it
keeps reappearing
but you got to get to the bottom of the
route to figure out exactly why this
issue keeps surfacing so you said this
has been going on for a while
okay so i'm 42 okay i came to the states
november 20
28 1990 which means i don't know
pre november 29 matter of fact i didn't
even follow politics for quite some time
so go even past that right if this has
been going on
forever has this been going on forever
as in since
biblical times pre-biblical times
meaning are we always going to go
through this 20 years from now 40 years
from now 80 years from now 300 years
from now 800 years 1 000 years or not
because it's a cyclical cycle of
one person makes the money the other one
says it's unfair he feels envious let's
take the money and give it to everybody
also
it's a constant pendulum that will go
through and it's never ending
or is it any way different today
than it was before 40 years from now 80
years from now 100 years from now 500
years from now
500 years ago well i i do think it's
worse now
than ever and it's getting worse but
like for example yesterday in class i
teach a course on marxism
we were talking about the hollywood ten
and
every single member of the hollywood ten
was was a was a member of communist
party usa
we had their five-digit communist party
usa numbers
in fact they were presented before the
members of uh
hollywood 10 when they were speaking to
congress october and november 1947.
house committee and un-american
activities john howard lawson who was
one of the worst of them
when he was called in to testify after
telling all of his liberal friends in
hollywood
humphrey bogart lauren bacall um you
know danny kaye
kelly some judy garland some of these
wonderful actors and actresses
who by the way were liberals right they
were not communists right they were
progressives
but he was telling them i'm not a
communist these right-wing fanatics in
washington d
i yeah i'm not that i'm not yeah i'm
like you so he got up there and he
testified before congress and they said
mr lawson
here on this billboard here on this um
poster board
here's your communist party usa number
here's all the checks you wrote out to
communist party usa
here's your dues here's your application
and and john howard lawson patrick
anyway did he kind of start in his seat
and he yelled
nazis right this is like
this is like the reichstag fire in
berlin he just started calling him names
right
he just started calling and these guys
all that they had done was exposed him
as being a communist so what did he do
he called him all these names probably
called him a homophobe if that name had
existed
back then right so so you see this among
the
the kind of extreme left for quite some
time i'll go back a little further
karl marx um i spent a lot of time on
this
in in the devil and karl marx marx and
these marxists
like to say that business people are are
capitalists who are obsessed with money
right
um no guys like marx and marxists and
communists
they're the ones who are obsessed with
money that's all that these guys
think about you you read some of marx's
anti-semitic statements
they are chilling right it says things
like
what is the worldly god of the jew money
what does the jew worship haggling and i
read that and i think to myself
no carl you're the one that worships
money right
you're the one that's obsessed with
money you're so obsessed with money that
you can't even think enough about your
own money
you think about everybody else's money
right you
you want you want a central government
to come in and forcibly take it and
redistribute it
so it's funny oftentimes when they're
yelling at you
haters screaming at them and you're
thinking i'm not hating at all i've got
a smile on my face while you're talking
to me
they're projecting on to you what
they're really feeling
and they do that a lot with um with with
money and attacking people with
property and attacking capitalists a lot
of this is a sort of self-projection
it's almost psychological by some of
these individuals
paul what was communism called
pre-communism
that's a good question and the i had a i
had a professor in graduate school who
used to like to say that
the jacobins were the first communists
right and so the jacobins of course were
there in revolutionary france
beheaded 40 000 people by guillotine in
one year between 1793 and 1794
and and of all things today in the
american left one of the more popular
avant-garde ideological magazines is
called the jacobin
and they have a little meme with with uh
with a guillotine
it's nothing to laugh about right
nothing to laugh about but marx and
engels in 1848 published the communist
manifesto
and that the communist manifesto was the
official programmatic statement or
manifesto
of the communist league in that day
which is made up of about
48 people all germans all men with the
exception of marx's wife i think she was
the only woman in the group
so at that point in time and people
tried to pin down
when who first used the word communism
the great richard pipes
the the harvard historian said that he
believed it was coined in paris
in the 1840s i don't know exactly for
sure
but marx and ingles met in paris in the
1840s
and uh and they published the communist
manifesto in 1848.
got it so so now before we talk about
carl
before we talk about reagan let's focus
on carl here so
who was carl growing up family
parents upbringing you know school
how was he in school what stories do we
need to know about him on that
influenced him to become
who he ended up becoming with writing
the book with english communist
manifesto
yeah he was he was born in germany may
5th 1818.
so trier is spelled like trier t-r-i-e-r
and it was it was one of the most
religious cities in all of germany
um very heavily roman catholic in fact
the ancient cathedral in trailer
was built in the 320s the 320s not the
1320s the 320s around the year 330
and it was built financed by helena
saint helena the mother of constantine
of all things
who made a pilgrimage to the holy land
and came back
with all sorts of artifacts
she believes that she found the actual
cross that christ was crucified on
the actual crown of thorns which to this
day
allegedly exi allegedly is the cross of
thorns that's
in notre dame in paris and she even
believes that she found the holy robe
which was the
the robe that christ wore on the way to
the crucifixion that the roman soldiers
cast lots for at the at the at the feet
at the feet of christ of the crucifix
that holy robe is in the cathedral and
trier
so marx grows up in a very very
religious city
his father the family was jewish
many rabbis in the family background
pretty faithful family father converted
to lutheranism probably at least in part
under the social pressures of the day
but the father always believed in god
patrick and he even said he would tell
carl he'd say you know
believing in god is a good thing for a
young man carl right it gives you some
accountability
something beyond yourself a sense of
ethics
right kind of a sense of absolute
something that you could follow
carl was baptized around the age of five
1823 1824 became a fairly
passionate christian through his teen
years
and then fled the faith in college where
probably the biggest influence in
college was a very anti-semitic theology
professor that he had named bruno bauer
who was such a bad theology professor
that
that the other the other faculty members
ran him out of the college he was he was
teaching
heresy and so so bruno bauer and his
favorite student karl marx together in
started what they called an archives of
atheism
a a journal of atheism which quickly
folded because they couldn't get any
support for it but at that point
he was um he pretty much put religion
behind him
in the 1840s and became a pretty uh
militant aggressive atheist after that
was there a follow-up between him and
his dad and his parents or no
oh yeah what was the following what
happened i i
quote a chilling letter in in the devil
and karl marx i think it was march 2nd
1837 march 1837
and it's a letter between marx and his
father and uh the father is very harsh
toward him in that letter and i i really
think it's
excessively harsh but but the
marx loved his father admired his father
and after that the father died not long
after that
and marx from there on looked to his
parents while his mom
primarily for money marx was horrible
about making money an absolute deadbeat
dad who would not provide for his wife
would not provide for his children
both his mother and his wife expressed
the wish that
carl would start earning some capital
instead of just
writing about capital he sent his wife
out begging for money
to his wife's in-laws uh carl went to
his own
in-laws the the only way that that
marx was able to do what he did was was
because of friedrich ingalls
because engels inherited a pile of money
from his capitalist wealthy
industrialist father
and and ingalls became marx's sugar
daddy
his subsidizer and frankly ingles was
pretty sick of it too
the way that carl all the time was was
pumping them for money
constantly mark marx refused to earn or
earn a living the the family his wife
jenny jenny's family was so upset
at carl's refusal to make any money that
the family lent
their nursemaid a girl named helene
demuth
who had grown up with jenny the family
loaned her out to carl and jenny
and they called they called her lynchin
carl refused to pay her a penny
and and in fact carl got her pregnant
behind jenny's back and then lynchin
helene had a baby carl refused to
admit that the child was his and of
course refused to pay the child a penny
a penny of child support so you know the
time the type of world that marx was
looking to create
would have been a world where where the
government took care of somebody like
carl
well he sat around on his butt with
carbuncles and
boils and refusing to bathe and
never earned a dollar i mean that's the
type of world that that he was looking
to create for himself
what was his logic like what was his
motive and logic behind that way of
thinking
in his own personal life yes and the way
he was like i'm not i'm brief he's going
to help out my wife
you know anybody what was his logic to
say i'm not moving people need to take
care of me not me taking care of them
was it because
he felt he was above people or because
he felt people
owed him something because of being
mistreated of what what was it
i don't think it was the latter he did
feel that people owed him something
he was he was very bitter and he was
very angry and and
superior to others oh yeah i mean marx
was
it was hard for marx ever to keep a
friend he eventually ran afoul of
everybody
um i quote some of the vitriol between
him
and mikhail bakunin who wrote god on
god the state in revolution no i'm
messing that up but but who was a
another
militant atheist and said oh here's carl
flinging his bile at me now like he does
at everybody
and ingalls was one of the only people
who hung with him
and in fact when when engel's mistress
died
ingalls ingalls did not believe in
marriage so he refused to marry
any of the women that he lived with but
he loved this woman
and carl wrote him a note where i mean
even the mark's biographers the
hagiographers the people who like
mark say oh this was really offensive
this was a low blow by marx
mark's in the first one or two three
lines
acknowledges the death of ingles um
girlfriend
and then gets on to the next 20 30 lines
with a more important question
of asking ingles for more money and
engels was so offended by this he wrote
back this diatribe letter
even my capitalist friends show more
sympathy than you and and he almost cut
marks off permanently
at that point but he came to realize
that marx was
this is how marx was right what was
thought about himself
what was engel's reasoning for wanting
to financially support marx what was
what's in it for him yeah the cause
the cause of communism and when ingalls
first met
marx he he referred to him in a poem as
the monster of ten thousand devils
the monster of ten thousand devils and
he talks about this poem
this black man from trier right he's
using black here
in the in the sense of darkened right
like like darkened figure this
foreboding presence
we had the strange allure too and
engel's faith story is much more
complicated
he had grown up a christian never really
wanted to leave the faith and always had
this kind of
so he felt carl like pulling him over to
the dark side
almost but they formed this partnership
the communist manifesto i quote in the
book
mark's um ingalls writing to marx carl
give a little more thought to the
communist
confession of faith i think we should
drop the catechetical form
and just call it the manifesto so they
even talked about this document that
they were writing
in religious like language so this
became something deeper for them this
was their calling
right this this was their vocation this
was this was like
almost a religious enterprise to them
and they hung in there and became
lifetime partners and wrote pretty much
um
everything together uh what the good
stuff that's written about marx who
wrote it and what good things did they
say about marx
well all the recent marx biographers
over the past
20 years are all pretty much
hagiographers right they just they
idolize the guy
these are like biographies for saints
they they
and and you really got to go through and
kind of pull out
the stuff from all of these to put
together the puzzle
it's so it's amazing at the stuff that
they ignore
they ignore all of all of marx's poetry
about the devil
which is what i focus on quite a bit but
earlier marxist
biographers and historians talked about
it
including um robert gee why can't i
think of his name that's terrible but
his biography of marx 1968 he published
robert payne um simon and schuster new
york university press nyu press
but but but the marxist biographers
today they tend to go
very easy on them because they like marx
marx is their guy and they're writing
kind of uh
how do they paint them what picture are
they painting with them like even
let's say they're trying to write sell
them as a this figure who
wanted to take care of the little guy
how did they sell him like what stories
do they have to say
that one time he saw a bird and it was
on the ground hurt and
he picked them up and brought him home
and fed him for three months and
built the ring and he winged and he flew
off like is there and what stories
are they telling about him yeah that's a
good question
i i mean the these are in many way love
letters in fact
one of the mark's biographers recent
ones her name is mary gabriel
and she wrote i think it's called love
and capital
which is a biography of karl marx and
his wife
and and i got that and i thought how can
this be a valentine right i mean how in
any way
it'd be fair to gabriel she does talk
about
some of the sordid stuff the bad stuff
the cheating
um you know mark's not fulfilling his
role as a husband
letting down jenny but at the same time
you know she really drills down and
accentuates and focuses on the nicer
things
about them so she doesn't ignore
everything
some other marx biographers though
they're they're pretty bad i'll give you
an example i don't want to call this guy
out by name but but i focus on a moment
between
marx and a guy named carl heinzen who
was a fellow socialist
and and mark's like corners heinzen
in his apartment and hindson said he was
staring at me with the eyes of a wet
goblin right he almost described in
certain demonic terms
we had just drank a couple bottles of
wine marx wouldn't let me out of the
apartment
and and marx is like taunting me and and
this guy heinz and finally said
if you don't get out of my way i'm going
to throw you down and he had to slam
marks down
and you know break out of the apartment
got outside went down the steps got
outside and marx is like yelling at him
from the apartment window
this biographer who tells this story his
first name is francis
he tells it he thinks it's charming he
thinks the story is charming
and i read that and i thought what the
what the hell how can i how could
anybody
you know i'm literally thinking hell i
mean the guy's describing marx in
like demonic terms eyes
like men marks like men or no was he
attracted to men i don't
i have never seen that okay i'm curious
i know i don't i don't know but how
anybody how two people this is
how two people could look at something
and one could say oh man this is
chilling this is all the other guys like
oh how charming but i i i think
it's the other guy's fault i know i'm
biased too but
i look at that and i don't think this
isn't charming this isn't funny
yeah so let me let me let me go a little
bit deeper in this so now
if you can just give us an idea about
what was the basic fundamental
foundation
of marxism or communism well marx and
ingles said
the entire communist theory or program
may be summed up in a single sentence
abolition of private property so there
you go
i mean that's so if you had marx and
ingles in the room and said hey
um in one sentence describe communism
they say well that's easy we did in the
communist manifesto
right the entire communist theory may be
summed up in the single sentence
abolition of private property
um beyond that they had other basic
little definitions mark said
communism begins where atheism begins
and
here if i may read just a couple of
bullet points this
is marx and the manifesto
marx and ingles and the manifesto
communism represents
the most radical rupture in traditional
relations
by the way which it sure does they
acknowledge that communism quote
seeks to abolish the present state of
things
right seeks to abolish the present state
of things of all things right
i mean this is key because we're going
from abolition of private property
to abolishing the present state of
things
so people who think and and young people
say this in surveys
well communism is a pretty good idea i
mean they talk about
love and sharing and sharing the wealth
no
read the book they talk about abolishing
the present state of things
these guys aren't tinkerers they're not
talking about like
increasing tax rates right they're not
talking about adding a couple programs
to the
to the welfare state abolish the present
state of things
what does that mean to you what does
that mean to you well it in in the
in the case of when you read the the
totality
of what they're writing it's it is truly
a totalitarian philosophy
and totalitarian in the strictest sense
of the word
a fundamental transformation of human
nature
i mean they are really looking to to
redefine human nature
the final paragraph of the communist
manifesto everybody remembers
workers of the world unite you have
nothing to lose but your chains
they write this in the final paragraph
the communists openly declare that their
ends can be attained
only by now listen to this only by the
forcible overthrow of all existing
social conditions okay our ends can be
attained
only by the forcible overthrow
of all existing social conditions
i mean you and i right we we we know
this is
as scholars and intellectuals you never
say all about anything
right you might say um communists call
for for the
forcible overthrow of those things in
society which are unjust
right they want the forcible overthrow
of
all existing social conditions
and it marks um here's one more phrase
in the manifesto close of the manifesto
last page of the manifesto communists
everywhere
support every revolutionary movement
against the existing social and
political order of things
now you hear that and you think to
yourself this explains a lot right
you might be watching a particular rally
on tv
a riot or whatever anything why is that
guy there with a hammer and sickle
what does that have to do with communism
wait they're protesting the unjust death
of george floyd
what's the communists doing there what
does that have to do with communism
well if whatever is going on right is
some sort of movement
against the existing social and
political order of things
these guys will be there right i mean
they'll team up if if it's redefining
marriage or gender or whatever else
something that might you might think
doesn't have anything to do with
capitalism or anything that these guys
could have thought of in the 1840s
if it's about redefining and
annihilating the existing and
social political order of things they'll
be there
paul do you think he wrote this book
with angles for them to
experience the power themselves or was
it
because i read somewhere where when this
book was taken by you know lennon stalin
all those guys it was
almost like they wanted to take
ownership for what this could happen but
carl couldn't fulfill his own prophecy
what was his long-term aspiration of
writing this book
so the book came out in 1848 so he had
been 30 years old
he died in 1883. ingalls died a little
bit after that
so you know he lives for 35 years
after the publication of the book and he
talks in some of his glowing moments
about
how communism will allow for him to fish
in the morning
farm in the afternoon raise cattle in
the evening
criticize after dinner right he talks
about in this very utopian language
as to whether he would have lived to see
it if he believed he lived to see it i
don't know
but but you know he talked about
communism as this dialectical march of
history
this inevitable march this is part of
the point of communism
this is inevitable they believe this is
the inevitable logic in march of history
in fact ingalls called it they called it
scientific socialism
and and engels said in his eulogy for
marx at marx's funeral
he said this is the darwin of the social
sciences
he has done for the social sciences what
darwin did for evolutionary biology
this is a natural evolution of history
so history would have would evolve from
feudalism slavery from feudalism and
slavery to capitalism
to socialism to communism right so
socialism would be the final
transitionary step to communism
lenin and the bolsheviks they get into
power
lenin at one point in january 1917 was
depressed he said i don't think i'll
live to see the revolution in my
lifetime
and then america declared war world war
one woodrow wilson april 2nd
got a war declaration in congress april
6 1917
the czar abdicated and the germans
put lenin on a box car and let him pass
through
dropped him in the middle of saint
peter's square and by october of 1917
the bolsheviks had their revolution
so um and marx and lenin and stalin and
these guys they believed
lenin wrote a number of important
articles and statements on this
they believed that the revolution needed
a vanguard
a regime a cadre a group of individuals
a kind of an anointed group
to raise the consciousness of the masses
and the workers right
you couldn't just wait for this to
transcend for this to evolve
no we got to abolish this now we got to
abolish that now
we got to get to work we got to take
power got it
so if you if you're looking at it right
now and you were to say the following
countries are
full on communism what would you say is
full-on communism based on their
definitions
castro's cuba the the castro brothers
right raul now fidel died a couple years
ago the kim's north korea
those are really textbook cases of
totalitarian communism
and you know and you get this all the
time somebody watching this will
probably complain
a marxist out there they say this all
the time patrick oh well that's not
really communism
right that's an aberration of communism
right yeah marx and engels would have
never supported
the gulags well you go go to marks and
engel's ten point
what they call for the forcible
overthrow of all existing conditions
forcible overthrow
go through their ten point plan they say
right there at the ten point plan
of course in the beginning this cannot
be affected except by means of despotic
inroads i mean they realize any any
you're a business person any um business
person non-business person
anybody should realize that if you make
a call for the abolition of private
property
you're going to have to use guns and
gulags i mean people
aren't going to roll over for that and
right then and there
you had you ought to say to yourself if
if this is an ideology that's going to
require
locking people up and killing them and
putting them on trains and
hurting them off to concentration camps
maybe we shouldn't go there
maybe this is a bad idea right uh
but but that's uh this is an ideology
that necessitates
prison camps i think it's unavoidable so
when you hear chinese communistic party
what what's communistic about china yeah
that's a great question and modern china
is such a weird case right so you have
you have a country that from 1949 to 76
under mao
and the cultural revolution the great
leap forward
that was full-blown maoism communism
as mao saw it right the signification of
marxism as he saw it
and then deng xiaoping came in in
1978-79
created what he called socialism with
chinese characteristics
where they reversed the collectivization
they started doing mass
privatizations they started freeing up
the economy
and basically they did what was no
longer economically communism
so you have the weird situation in china
to this day where you have a country
that's politically communist
a one-party communist state but not
economically communist
so yeah what does that mean one
political party communist government is
communism what does it mean government
is communism
well and this is where this is where the
soviet union was right
and and the big thing that mikhail
gorbachev did in 1990
they abolished article 10 or is it
article 6 of the soviet constitution
which had a communist party monopoly on
political power
and you know every every communist state
ever
you can only have one political party by
the way and you can't have free
elections
because people won't vote for communists
right
when i mentioned the the the elections
in poland in june 1989 earlier
patrick they put 100 seats up for
contested elections
communists lost 100 out of 100
okay they didn't win a single seat right
that's why castro's cuba won't hold
elections
this is why they don't hold elections
because people will vote communists out
people in the western like communism is
a pretty good idea they don't live
under it right then why don't the people
ever vote for why don't the leaders
allow them people to vote for it
so in china you have a single party
communist party controlled state
that doesn't allow political parties the
leader of the party is the chairman the
president whatever becomes the leader of
the country
and they're smart enough to realize that
if they want an economy that works
you can't do true economic communism
you gotta allow enough free market
reforms that you won't go
broke and starve to death so it's weird
what they're doing with communism in
china it's a very different thing it's
and it's totally unlike north korea or
cuba
the way i see it is chinese communistic
party let's just say the government is
communism is
no freedom of speech you can't have an
opinion you better do as they say and
everything else you can make money
yeah but the moment jack ma you think
you're bigger than us and you give a
speech on october 24th of last year
calling out the regulators and the
government employees let me tell you
here's your 2.8 billion dollar fine we
have
new regulation about monopoly and we are
shutting you down and you're not going
public and ant group's going to be
overhaul and all this other stuff
because you crossed the line you started
thinking you're bigger than china
and you're not so zip it don't say
single ward against us
or else okay fair enough so now who
would you say today
in america if you were to say the most
influential person in america
that follows and would like to aspire
one day for america
to be what karl marx talks about in his
book communism
communist manifesto who would aspire to
see america become that if you were to
say
big name not small name big names well
that's a good question i mean for that
sort of hardcore you'd have to go to
like communist party usa
website is cpusa.org you'd have to go to
like the trotskyist socialist workers
party
um the the editors at the people's world
which is peoplesworld.org that's the
successor to the daily worker
there's a guy named bob avakian
who runs the revolutionary communist
party
revcom they're known as babavakian
is armenian yeah i that's a good
question it probably is armenian
yeah a v a k i a n
um if you look it up bob ovakian they
call them
chairman bob and he's got at his website
his website revcom
revolutionary communist party usa is all
about him
so do you see it yeah yeah that's it he
is armenian by the way he's an american
armenian american lawyer civil rights
activist and later judge on alameda
county uh california superior court
interesting
yeah so he he's he's a leader and
he is when you saw last summer or last
year patrick
that um communist party endorses joe
biden for president
i remember i saw i got that email
immediately because of who i am right in
my email box and i thought
wow that's weird communist party usa i
know that they're for
biden and for the democrat every four
years but they you don't usually endorse
them because that hurts the
the endorsement hurts so i clicked that
it wasn't communist party usa it was
it was chairman bob it was bob ovakian
he's the one that endorsed biden
for that is he is he a guy that debates
and gets on different platforms and
interviews or no
i don't think he does much from what i
can tell he's mostly solo
and and posts for a while he was in
exile
and possibly in paris and i have often
wondered if it was a
self-imposed exile well we'll definitely
reach out to them because we've had
slavo and jiji
khan and we've had uh professor richard
wolfon
and a few other guys on so i'm always
curious to know to speak to them so okay
so
i think is it fair to say that the kind
the topic of communism is not creating a
lot of momentum
in u.s at all it's not like it's gonna
one day be a threat to u.s
again like it was back in the days under
reagan well here's the threat and here
i think is the longer answer to your
question the people today who are
sympathetic to communism
are calling themselves democratic
socialists
and and so if there's a kind of leader
for that today first of all there's
bernie sanders
okay and bernie sanders was a
formal presidential elector to the
socialist workers party
in 1980 and 1984. so 1980 when most
normal americans are deciding whether to
vote between carter or reagan right
bernie sanders was supporting the
trotskyist socialist workers party
we've never found proof that bernie
was an actual member of the socialist
workers party but you look in his
background
he's long been a supporter of it and
probably knew better
than to actually formally join it daniel
greenfield of frontpagemagazine.com
david horowitz's freedom center
ron radosh look up their writings on
bernie's time
in a stalinist kibbutz in israel
in the early 1960s so bernie was
way to the far left bernie was never a
democrat until 2016 when he sought the
democratic party's nomination
he was an independent james carville
right said
bernie's not a democrat why is he
running as a democrat he's not even a
dem he's not he's not a democrat
but he came in second for the democratic
party presidential nomination in 2016
and 2020.
bernie's a lifetime socialist but one
more thing
the trotskyist socialist workers party
they published the publication the
militant
and the militant you can look up online
lee harvey oswald
the assassin of jfk holding the rifle in
one hand that he shot jfk
with and a copy of the militant
newspaper in the other hand
that's been around for a long time the
other leaders of the sort of modern
socialism the democratic socialism as
they call it
it's the democratic socialists of
america
that's the group that's it patrick that
is
it communist party usa says that they've
had a membership
surge where they're now at about 5 000
members
all right that sucks right the
democratic socialists of america
are are in a true membership surge and
are now up to about 90
000 altogether and their poster girl
is alexandria ocasio-cortez and the
other one
in fact if they have poster girls it's
the squad
um ilhan omar who i think is
the most radical member of the house
and the third one is rasheeda toleb
who who said of donald trump we need to
impeach the mother
you know blank and the fourth one is
eliana presley although i don't think
presley
is um is an actual democratic socialist
but she's part of the squad
so that's really that's where the
momentum is today
so if you if you look up democratic
socialists online look up look up
democratic socialists of america um
annual convention communist
international
and they're they're singing the the
at the start of their at the start of
their convention and calling each other
comrades
right so they uh they'll they'll say oh
we're not
communist we're not even socialists
we're democratic
socialists but but when you hear the
rhetoric and see what they say and you
see what they read
like richard pipes said you know there's
no meaningful distinction between
socialism and communism
um oftentimes there's indeed not so
if we look at communism and they define
angles and uh
and uh marx say the abolition of
uh uh abolition of property right and
then you
have the at the end of the book forcible
overthrows of all existing social
condition okay right it's fine so we
have those two definitions then what how
would you define
socialism and uh lenin wrote
in the state and revolution which is
this kind of
opus and he wrote that in 1917
couldn't finish writing it because
because the revolution overtook them
but he wrote in there he said as mark
said
in in in communism socialism is just the
final transitionary step
before communism so you know the it
it's one phase that leads to a higher
phase
marian smith who was the executive
director of victims of communist
memorial foundation
says well uh just as religious believers
christians and jews aspire to heaven the
socialist aspires to communism
right communism is the sort of new
jerusalem
you know that's that's the that's the
utopia that's that's the heaven on earth
so in true marxist leninist theory
socialism is the final transitionary
step to communism
now that said you'll run into all sorts
of socialists today who say well
but that's not the kind of socialist
that i am right
i don't support communism i wouldn't go
that far
i support single-payer health care i
support maybe government
taking over the energy sector
i support this and well all right fine
but if you type in a google or
merriam-webster
socialism what will pop up is socialism
common ownership of the means of
production so
you know historically socialism that's
what it is ussr
union of soviet socialist republics it's
the final transitionary step to
communism
it makes you it makes you wonder so so
i'm a math guy i'm a numbers guy because
it makes sense to me and it's absolute
right so if i look at communism
communism if i go on one side 100 to me
is communism
okay so is there a way to come up with a
number that tells us where socialism is
when it comes down to taxes
has that study been done because arthur
laffer said yes around 33 and a half 34
and a half percent and
you know you've seen a lot of different
studies but is there a
way to quantify what socialism is since
we know how to quantify
communism that's a great question i love
that and
in my comparative politics course at
grove city college every fall
we use the heritage foundation's index
of economic freedom
they rank countries from number one to
about number 170
most economically free to least
economically free
and the top two have been hong kong and
singapore
pretty much ever since they started
doing this study in the 1990s
and then you have new zealand maybe
ireland
maybe the uk maybe the united states
we're around the top ten
and then china i think is usually around
like 100 120.
um spain italy france you know who knows
30s 70s they're all over the place but
at the very end
the very end is always north korea and
cuba cuba
yeah so in a way i that that guide i
find
very very useful as as kind of
a ranking system and a country there
that would be
around 150 venezuela's down to the
bottom now too
zimbabwe is down at the bottom so i'd
say when you're in that
range of like the bottom 10 percent
bottom 20
150 to 170 you're kind of in you know
collectivism
socialism communism you know that
you're you're in that territory got it
but there's never been a number that
they've put to it meaning give tax if
you pay more than 60
taxes it's socialism if you're paying
more than 30 taxes at socialism what
that that's what i'm looking for yeah
that's a good question yeah
and to do it through tax rates to truly
have
abolition of private property by the way
the top three
in marx and engel's ten point plan
abolition of property and land
graduated or progressive income tax oh
and my favorite
abolition of all right of inheritance
all right so abolition of all right of
inheritance would technically
mean right for you and i who are
practical guys are trying to figure out
what these
guys are saying that would have to be
like 100
inheritance tax right death tax
so if you have a 100 tax on inheritance
is the only way you're going to abolish
all right of inheritance
that would be communism um i know if you
have a 50
tax rate on inheritance i'd like to call
that socialist
i think it's pretty damned outrageous
70 percent would be outraged tax rates
in the united states we introduced the
federal income tax in 1913 permanent
federal income tax it was a few
percentage points
by 1921 under woodrow wilson it was 73
fdr took it up to 94
on income over 100 000 and fdr
if you read bert folsom's book fdr goes
to war fdr in the 1940s wanted a
99.5 tax rate
on incomes over 100 000 now i would call
that pretty close to communism
he might not be quoting marks when he's
doing it but i'd have to say that that
would be pretty close
a 99.5 tax rate on income over a hundred
thousand dollars
that's like almost complete confiscation
and redistribution of wealth
at that point but to pick a hard number
marx and engels never gave one
and this is infuriating for practical
minded business people
they also they would say well you know
at this point
you've left capitalism and then
socialism and then capital
i want to know at which point in the
process we're there
right i want to know who's the vanguard
who's the group of leaders that say oh
okay all right okay we are now comrades
from point b to point c right
i can now say that we've officially
entered
communist society none of this is ever
clear
and it has to be decided by dictators
that's what it comes down to
very interesting by the way on the 99.5
i mean
i would i would love to know what's the
right book to read where it's going to
be unbiased and it's going to tell me
what was his motive and taking it to
99.5 like what
is it it's bert folsom
uh fdr goes to war he wrote it with his
wife
anita he's a hillsdale professor retired
hillsdale what's the book about
um it's called fdr goes to war i got it
so it's about the 1940s
and um yeah 99.5 right by the way people
thinking
well he must have just wanted it for
wartime no
no no no no fdr fdr was jacked the rate
up to 91
the reason ronald reagan left the
democratic party
was um over fdr's tax rates and that's
that's what drove him out of the
democratic party that
probably more than anything else that's
right because in hollywood they were
getting crushed with the taxes
but it was at the top so it's okay so
now let's talk about let's talk about
reagan
um who was reagan and how did reagan
come to his
political conclusions of eventually
obviously becoming the president
of the united states well so he was
he had been um raised an fdr democrat he
called himself a hemophiliac liberal
a bleeding heart liberal he was a new
dealer from the midwest
and i mean that's my family too my
family's from western pennsylvania
coal mines steel mills pittsburgh and
you know in those days they it was kind
of the party of god
guns and labor in those days right
um it's interesting that's what donald
trump really tapped into
here in western pennsylvania fracking
industry west virginia coal mining
but so ronald reagan came out of that
group
his mother was very religious very very
religious
and when reagan went out to hollywood in
the 1930s started making movies a lot of
movies
1930s and 1940s among other things he
became weary
of of kind of this hyper new deal
collectivism
redistributionism high tax rate
tax rates were reagan called creeping
socialism
where you started this new program that
new program this new program pretty soon
how do we pay for all of this well how
do you pay for it
well you increase taxes right on who
on the rich all right well how do you
get any higher than 91 percent
well we go to 94 right how about 99.5
right yeah margaret thatcher said the
problem with socialism is you eventually
run out of other people's money
at some point so that got to reagan and
what really got to reagan
was he saw the communist infiltration
of hollywood reagan saw that with the
screen actors guild he was president of
the screen actors guild
and he also saw reagan became a popular
after dinner speaker
in hollywood in the 1940s where he would
go around giving the speech
exoriating nazism
fascism and one day after he gave this
speech
to men's group at his church the pastor
of the reverend cleveland kleihauer came
up to reagan and said
hey ron that's a great speech you know
nazism
fascism evil evil evil evil evil
you know hitler's dead there's no
movement in the united states at all for
nazism you know the war was over three
years ago you know ron out there right
now there's another threat out there
it's called communism
and it's it's pretty brutal too and i
think your speech would be a lot more
powerful if maybe you just added in a
little criticism
about communism and reagan patrick said
well that's a pretty good idea i think
i'll start doing that
so reagan gives his typical stump speech
and he's giving it to one of these
progressive groups in washington right
and sitting there
you know the john howard lawson dalton
trombo hollywood ten types
way to go ron way to go you know get
those nazis get those fascists and then
reagan gets the end of the speech
he writes about this in his memoirs and
he said at the end of the speech he said
he said you know there's another ism out
there and it's called communism
another totalitarianism and i'll tell
you if that ever
becomes a threat to the united states
like nazism was
i will condemn that just as harshly and
patrick reagan said you could hear a pin
drop
a pin drop right and and he said
he got called names um
witch hunter red baiter fascist scum
all of a sudden he's like persona non
god he's like what am i doing
and he realized reagan said the reds
weren't under the bed
you know they were they were in the bed
and a lot of these progressive groups
that he thought were good-hearted
liberals
like him were actually pro-communists so
if
this awakened reagan to the communist
threat
in hollywood and the united states and
all of that that
fdr everything else began pushing him
out of the democratic
party and toward eventually the
republican party in conservatism
um he i'm currently finishing up jim
baker's book
uh i don't know if you've read it or not
the story the man who ran washington i
don't know if you've been
i haven't read it i should yeah he's
he's got a he gives a different angle on
reagan and
uh also i'm not sure if you've read
killing reagan i'm sure you read killing
reagan by bill o'reilly
oh yeah you know he kind of takes it he
pissed off george will
and george will was one of the guys that
inspired me
uh march of 2009 when i heard him speak
at miramar hotel when i was invited to
an event by larry
greenfield from the claremont institute
with larry arn and i heard him speak and
uh uh
pat boone was and all these other guys
but uh
today where we are today you're a
historian
you've read a lot obviously you're
biased on one side strong conservative
you even said it yourself earlier we
said listen even me as a person who's
biased when you look at the part saying
where he is not letting his friend go
down i mean that's just that what do you
mean romantic or what do you mean by you
know the words that the guy used
i even i'm biased that doesn't sound
romantic to me
uh i don't know if that's the word used
you may use a different word but you
know i i get what you were saying
what is your biggest concern today we're
in america today
you know we just got done with a fourth
term you know four
years of donald trump which you know
if you're watching cnn msnbc he's the
worst president of all time if you're
watching fox he's the goat
if you're reading wall street journal
he's great for the economy but he's
rattling too many cages you know if you
depending on
what you read you have a different
interpretation of who donald trump is
and
we go through chronovirus momentum
creates
voting changes the way we're going to
vote biden wins
we wait six weeks to find out georgia
wins
both seats and then biden inauguration
trump doesn't show up first time ever
and
now we have america today what is your
biggest concern
of where we are today well i'd say
indeed this riot is in support for
socialism
people's lack of understanding of it um
and i and two the entire canceled
culture and just how nasty
and vicious people are to one another in
fact ronald reagan came from an era
where where people could disagree
and and and you know the people in the
1980s on the left side
who disagree with ronald reagan at least
they liked him as a person
they didn't feel that that you that you
had to ruin someone's life
this idea today i mean somebody will
watch this today
and not like what i say and and want to
write a letter to the president of my
college demanding i'd be fired you know
it's it people so personalize
everything uh there's a real lack of
charity
of kindness of decency of people really
getting along like ladies and gentlemen
and having
you know genuine disagreement and also
two people just
aren't thoughtful they're not well read
they're not taking the time to research
things
i had a group of faculty at a college
where i was supposed to supposed to
speak in california
last semester um asked that the
invitation to be to me be withdrawn
and further evidence against what i had
done they
they quoted some obscure online
publication i hadn't even heard of
and from which they took like a two-line
summary of a book that i wrote
and it was all that they had patrick and
i thought these are fellow academics
i mean read the book i i i mean
how lazy is that i i mean about
not just nasty but lazy but this is the
kind of culture that
that we're in and it makes me not very
optimistic
i mean is the reaganos story and reagan
talked about the shining city on a hill
i mean i i feel that we're not that
shining city anymore
and it's going to be to turn this around
i don't i don't know what it's going to
take but 30 years
30 plus years after the collapse of
communism
we should not be having the debate as to
whether or not communism was bad
and the fact that we are shows that
we're really in trouble as a country
you think you get to a point where
people are going to leave america and go
to different places to live just like
everybody else came from other countries
to want to live in america you think
america is eventually going to get to a
point of losing citizens
possibly i mean ronald reagan said if we
lose freedom here there's no place to
escape to this is the last stand on
earth and he was talking at that point
about talking to a cuban refugee
that was reagan's 1964 time for choosing
speech
so i still wonder well it's true if we
lose freedom here
where else are we going to go to but i
could see some
people especially professional people
feeling so harassed
by the woke mobs and everybody else in
america
where they say you know i've had enough
of this i'll go live in europe or
something
but in a way you can't escape social
media
right you can't escape the the power of
the internet
and twitter and everything else so it
takes a special kind of person i think
in toughness
to withstand this ignore it and simply
say maybe like what reagan said right
well there they go again right and just
and kind of shrug it off and say well
this is what they do this is how they
attack and
they're calling me a racist now well
they've done it to everybody they did it
to reagan by the way they're really
doing that to reagan now
right uh so it's just it's kind of what
they do
they're vicious about it and um i guess
all we can do maybe try to teach people
to be more respectful of one another
but good luck how do you deal with that
with teaching the youth i mean you're
seeing what's going on with
uh china giving 400 billion dollars to
iran 25-year contract okay that they're
going to get oil in return but at the
same time
influence and education influence and
infrastructure influence and you know
etc etc and then you're hearing about
new york giving 15 600
to undocumented immigrants who lost
their work
during the pandemic and you know they're
going to spend the state budget of 2.1
billion dollars to helping out
and they're raising taxes well for the
top line revenue
uh officially new york becomes the most
expensive state to live in
it's no longer california california
becomes a second wars used to be the
worst
on taxes how are some of these people
making these kinds of policies and
making progress on them and people are
buying into them
and the job creators are sitting on the
sidelines saying well you know what i'm
going to take it a little bit more are
you sensing
the exit is actually taking place from
some states
and some of these states are really
going to pay a big price just like maybe
they did in 1970
when half of the fortune 500 companies
out of new york left and
completely left to a different state do
you see some states getting crushed
yeah i do and this is a whole other
fiscal conversation about the
bankrupting of america i mean there's
only so much longer that this kind of
spending and this kind of debt can go on
we've been saying that for a long time
but it's got to reach a tipping point at
some point
but but but also though too to have
those people then
leave new york and california and go to
states like texas and colorado
and georgia and then they come down and
they bring their their crazy
voting preferences with them uh and then
and then turn you know southern states
and republican states
into into northeastern states uh
and and in a place like like georgia
where corporations like coca-cola and
even major league
baseball an organization like that
starts politicizing everything
i mean they have no idea if the laws in
georgia are more restrictive than my
home state of pennsylvania
they're probably not right coke doesn't
know that
major league baseball doesn't know that
but you get
again this kind of mob media platform
media mentality
this culture of intimidation of cancel
and it starts going after people and
people get scared
and they buckle and and i find that to
go back to what i said
i find that one of the more disturbing
things about
america today in the 21st century i mean
we're at the last part of the interview
paul i'm going to give you names it's
called speedrun tell me one word that
comes to mind
okay aoc democratic socialist i use two
words
okay sanders socialist
pelosi oh boy
that's not easy i'm trying not to be
insulting i was gonna pick a word that's
insulting there
um i i yeah
yeah i better i shouldn't say what i
just talked about charity right
what what what i would say would not be
um
positive about her in in my view
mental acuity on on on certain policy
issues
how about biden i think it's a trojan
horse
kamala yeah
president harris obama
obama uh increasingly difficult to pin
down
i'm starting to wonder patrick if if if
obama
almost like a bill maher type is kind of
moving a little bit more to the center
as he gets disgusted watching the cancel
culture and some of this other stuff go
around
him but that's not a one-word answer is
it yeah yeah but but it's very
interesting you're saying that because
you wrote about his mentor
yeah frank marshall davis yeah so it's
it's interesting so
and his presidency i think was a really
bad turning point
that that i i i could show you by data
that when they ask they ask young
americans every year
do you support socialism or capitalism
all right it finally flipped to
socialism in 2010
right a lot of this cultural
revolutionary stuff happened under obama
uh obama was really a br the obama
presidency was a breakthrough period for
the left
that i don't think we'll will ever turn
back from even if obama has some regrets
if he ever does about some of what
happened
got it so ted right ted cruz
great yeah i think he's terrific he's
one of my favorite senators my favorite
senators are ted cruz marco rubio rand
paul
jfk uh anti-communist democrat
partners his party is no longer with us
i agree bill maher i i
i appreciate his independence i can't
watch his show because of the vulgarity
and the other stuff
but i appreciate somebody who's honest
and and is willing to he's like piers
morgan right
willing to say what what um willing to
go against the politically correct on
his side
anderson cooper i actually think he's
pretty fair
i i um yeah yeah tucker
brilliant and and needs to continue to
be courageous
be not afraid jon stewart
uh yeah he's a little bit like a bill
maher and john stewart i like he's a
nice guy he doesn't have a mean edge to
him
trump that would take another entire
show
[Laughter]
to adequately assess him but
turn policy wise turned out to be
a much more conservative president and
and
many of the policies that i thought he
would never embrace
in 2016 he did by 2020. pence
um really nice guy i don't think he'll
ever be president though
desantis um i think he could be
president and he's a really good
governor
well i got to tell you i've really
enjoyed this thank you so much for being
a guest on valuetainment and
we're going to put the links to two of
your books which we talked about today
the devil and karl marx we're going to
put the link below as well as the
crusader ronald reagan and the fall of
communism
and uh we'll put the links for folks to
be able to find you as well whether it's
your website or your social media
platform
final thoughts here before we wrap up is
there any last words you got for the
audience
well i don't use social media my twitter
account i've never actually touched so i
gotta warn you on that
but yeah my final uh my final advice
would be educate educate
educate you might have to self-educate
yourself and all this stuff
especially if you go to our lousy
universities and have courage
have charity be not afraid and try to be
a cheerful
warrior in this culture that needs uh
cheerful warriors
ronald reagan was a fearful warrior i
like that cheerful
who are you patrick i appreciate that
thank you so much thank you for your
time thank you for being a guest on
valuetainment
thank you very much god bless take care
bless you as well you have no idea how
much i enjoy watching
interviews or doing interviews on topics
of economy like it's so fascinating to
me
and some of you either love this stuff
or some of you didn't even make it all
the way to the end but if you did i want
to know what you took away
from today's interview and if you
enjoyed today's interview there's two
other interviews i want to recommend
watch either one of them that you want
to watch one of them was with ray dalio
at the time when i interviewed him i
think he was worth 18 billion
and we had a very very deep conversation
about economy
methods of thinking china was a big part
of it you may enjoy this one and if
you've not watched my sit down with
larry arn
larry arn has a lot of similar
philosophies to
my guest today paul i think you would
really enjoy
the conversation with larry yarn as well
having said that click on each
either one of them that you want to
watch and aside from that have a
wonderful day take care everybody bye
[Music]